[Musik]
ganz Deutschland diskutiert wieder über
ihn Karl Lauterbach Deutschlands
grünster SPD-Minister will jetzt das
Kiffen legalisieren vom Corona
panikminister zum volksvorsteher darüber
müssen wir unbedingt reden so richtig
schummrig wird meinen Gästen allerdings
erst beim Gedanken an unsere
wirtschaftliche Zukunft allerdings aus
ganz unterschiedlichen Gründen und damit
herzlich willkommen hier bei viertel
nach acht mit diesen spannenden Gästen
heute Birgit Kelle sie ist Publizistin
und sie hält Lauterbachs kifferpläne für
extrem gefährlich Cannabis sei eine
Einstiegsdroge die Gesundheit unserer
Kinder in großer Gefahr ja und für ihn
hat Deutschland noch ein ganz anderes
Problem wir schaffen uns wirtschaftlich
ab sagt Oliver Stock Chefredakteur vom
wirtschaftskurier noch sei für made in
Germany aber nicht alles verloren so
können es allerdings nicht weitergehen
ja und der größte wirtschaftskiller sind
eh die russland-sanktionen das meint
Ökonom Prof dr Hassan alkasch damit
würden uns nicht nur ins Knie sondern
direkt ins Gehirn schießen also weg
damit steile These ja und weg damit
damit bin ich dann auch bei Ingwer
perovanovic er meint unsere
Kernindustrie der fahrradaktivist der
will Autos komplett aus der Stadt
verbannen am besten sofort jede Menge
Zündstoff also und Zündstoff ist
tatsächlich ein gutes Stichwort Frau
Kelle beim Thema Stoff anzünden dann
gehen sie nämlich so richtig an die
Decke sie sind gegen die Legalisierung
erklären Sie uns mal bitte warum ich bin
gespannt Ihre Kamera
nachdem man den deutschen seit Jahren
alles mögliche verbieten will vom
Autofahren über das Fliegen und das
Fleisch essen will man uns jetzt also im
Gegenzug die Drogen legalisieren
ganze zwei Jahre hat man uns im Namen
der Bürgerrechte sogar die
im Namen des Gesundheitsschutz die
Bürgerrechte weggenommen und jetzt will
man es also im Gegenzug Drogen zur
Beruhigung geben ich glaube das Kiffen
nicht harmlos ist ich bin Mutter von
vier Kindern und ich habe schon vor 30
Jahren in meinem eigenen Freundeskreis
gesehen wie Cannabis die Einstiegsdroge
war und später Kokain oder eben auch
synthetische Drogen zu nehmen Lauterbach
behauptet nun es führe zu einem besseren
Gesundheits- und Jugendschutz wörtlich
sagte er das Gesetz wird auch den Konsum
insbesondere bei jungen Menschen
reduzieren bessere Gesundheit und
weniger Konsum sind das Ziel auch der
Justizminister Buschmann sagt die
Legalisierung bedeutet eine bessere
Produktqualität also besseres Hasch ich
bin gespannt ob er sich demnächst auch
um reineres Heroin oder aber auch um
kristallkarre klares Koks für die
deutschen bemühen wird das Gesetz wird
ein kaum kontrollierbares
Bürokratiemonster werden der
Schwarzmarkt den man angeblich bekämpfen
wird wird auch bleiben wir haben die
Beispiele in Kanada und auch in
Kalifornien wo der Schwarzmarkt in
weiterhin floriert die
Polizeigewerkschaften waren die
Apotheken warnen die Fachärzte warnen
trotzdem möchte unsere Regierung hier
weitermachen und logisch ist das ganze
eigentlich auch nicht denn wer eine
Droge legalisiert der schafft den Markt
nicht ab sondern pusht ihn sogar nach
oben
sehr steile These Frau Kelle wir haben
direkt mal was vorbereitet für sie nicht
nur für sie eigentlich für alle aber
erstmal für sie schauen Sie mal hier wir
haben auf der einen Seite man schönes
Glas Rotwein ich trinke Weißwein
wir hätten auch Weißwein nehmen können
es ist ein Symbol weil so und wir haben
hier noch ein weiteres Symbol wir haben
einen schönen joint wenn man das jetzt
mal einfach nebeneinander legt was ist
für Sie der große Unterschied
der große Unterschied ist für mich dass
das legal ist und das illegal ist weil
es auch durchaus einen Grund gibt warum
ist das
illegal und das legal
grundsätzlich kann man sagen irgendwie
weil das Gesetz so gemacht worden ist
zweitens weil das eine Droge ist die
unkalkulierbar ist und im übrigen auch
sehr schwer dosierbar ist also die ich
habe auch mal gekifft als ich
Jugendliche war und fast dann so wie
fast alle das wahrscheinlich einmal auch
mal ausprobiert haben
das ist das ist etwas was die
Gehirnstruktur verändern kann was ihnen
auch Fachärzte bei Jugendlichen ja aber
auch bei Erwachsenen es ist ja nicht so
also es ist ja so dass sehr viele auch
darauf hängen bleiben und dass es vor
allen Dingen auch die Hemmschwelle und
das wissen wir leider auch die
Hemmschwelle senkt auch Sommer stärkere
Drogen zu sich zu nehmen das halte ich
im Übrigen für die gefährlichste das
gefährlichste Problem in dieser Sache
das ist ja eben nicht nur sozusagen um
die Tüte geht die man ab und zu mal
raucht sondern das ist das der Effekt
ganz offensichtlich sichtbar ist bei
vielen und ich kenne wie gesagt allein
in meinem persönlichen Umfeld einige
also Eltern deren Kinder quasi auf den
Drogen hängen geblieben sind in meiner
Jugend hatte ich mehrere in meiner
Clique auch die umgestiegen sind weil es
sozusagen irgendwann reicht das nicht
mehr und irgendwann braucht man etwas
stärkeres aber sind das hat man vom Kern
kam und haben die nicht auch Alkohol
getrunken könnte nicht Alkohol genauso
eine Einstiegsdroge sein ist Alkohol
nicht auch genauso gefährlich für
Jugendliche Gehirne für die Entwicklung
ja deswegen sind sie auch bei
Jugendlichen verboten im übrigen genau
aber das soll ja also Karl Lauterbach
erwachsen sein ja es soll für Erwachsene
sein insofern finde ich das auch sehr
erstaunlich aber die wir wissen
natürlich auch dass dieses das ist nur
für Erwachsene so und für Kinder erst ab
18 wird ja nicht funktionieren sie
glauben doch nicht dass es keine dass
die Jugendlichen sich das nicht
beschaffen der Unterschied wird jetzt
sein dass der 18-Jährige der für seine
Minderjährigen Freunde das ganze kauft
das ganze jetzt auch noch legal besorgen
kann also ich finde dass Signal fatal
bleiben wir aber mal bei den Erwachsenen
geht ja darum die zu entkriminalisieren
Menschen die einfach genauso wie sie
abends gerne mal in Glas Wein trinken
sagen nee Alkohol ist jetzt eher nicht
meins ich trinke zum Entspannung ziehe
ich einfach mal am Joint warum sind
diese Menschen Kriminelle und die
anderen nicht
im Moment sind sie so weil das Gesetz
ist so regelt ich halte es allerdings
auch die Frage wir können ja die Frage
auch ausweiten warum verbieten wir
irgendwie Ecstasy also ich kenne auch
Leute die sagen wieso Ecstasy habe ich
während meiner Prüfung genommen hat
super gewirkt es gibt auch andere
Aufputschmittel die sie bleiben Rezept
gibt also wie ich sagen wir können die
wir könnten sie könnten auch eine
heroinen bringen also es gibt aber Leute
ja ist nicht dasselbe aber sie sehen wir
sehen Sie das sie glauben sie dass
Alkohol und kiffen was völlig anderes
sind dass man die völlig anders
behandeln sollte also wenn es nicht
anders wäre dann würden die Strafen ja
nicht so hoch sein also als
Richter bzw als Schöffe gerade in Kleve
habe ich sehr oft mit solchen Fällen zu
tun wo dann halt mit welchen Fällen
genau ja also mit drogenfällen die dann
halt von Holland oder Niederlanden
sozusagen nach Deutschland sozusagen
transportiert werden und wenn ich dann
überlege allein für die für den
Transport ja von von 30 Gramm oder wird
schon ein paar Jahre Leben und die
Gesetzesmacher die haben sicherlich sich
was dabei gedacht dass ihr sozusagen von
heute auf morgen so völlig zu
legalisieren finde ich zum einen aus
Gesundheitsaspekten also da stimme ich
Frau Kerle zu aber auch sozusagen aus
dem Signal wie man der Bevölkerung das
jetzt irgendwie erklären will dass man
also quasi für einen Kurierdienst im
Jahr sechs Jahre Strafe gibt und jetzt
auf einmal soll das jetzt sagen also
frei sein also ich bin kein kein
überzeugter zu klauen ist auch
verbotenes zu verkaufen oder ist zu
fahren natürlich nicht
das ist klar aber die sozusagen also die
diese Menge
als es legal zu konsumieren oder zu
kaufen also
kommen wir auf das will ja keiner Ändern
der Aspekt also eine der Hauptbegründung
ist ja dass man sagt irgendwie die es
haben nicht es habe nicht zu einem
geringeren Drogenkonsum geführt dass es
verboten ist also man sagt verbote
bringen nichts wer legalisieren und
Regeln sozusagen und wir bauen damit den
Schwarzmarkt angeblich und
entkriminalisieren ich glaube das ist
einer der Hauptpunkte zu sagen dass die
normale Erwachsenen
Schutz und Jugendschutz ja also wie man
durch die Legalisierung einer Droge
Jugendschutz betreibt ist mir wirklich
ein Rätsel und der Schwarzmarkt das ist
eine grob ein großes eine große
Begründung ist man wolle den
Schwarzmarkt sozusagen abbauen ja wann
muss doch einfach mal schauen was in der
Welt passiert irgendwie in diesen
Ländern in Kanada hat hat es nicht dazu
geführt dass der Schwarzmarkt abgebaut
wurde im Gegenteil der ist irgendwie
etwa dreimal so groß wie der legale
Markt warum weil natürlich das Hasch auf
dem Schwarzmarkt nach wie vor deutlich
günstiger ist als in den lizenzierten
Shops also läuft das weiter in
Kalifornien derselbe Effekt auch da
schätzt man das zum Beispiel etwa die
die illegalen Felder zum Anbau etwa 10
also eine 10 Mal so große Fläche
einnehmen wie die legalen Felder das
heißt dieses Argument ist nicht da ja
gerne also einmal sozusagen die
Lebenswirklichkeit spricht so ein
bisschen dagegen wir haben ich sitze
regelmäßig mit Freunden zusammen die
einen haben sowas in der Hand der
anderen dringenden rotweinig gehört zur
rotweinfraktion und ich muss sagen wer
ich wenn ich am nächsten Morgen aufwache
bin ich derjenige der den Schädel habe
den geht's meistens gut also das
vielleicht nur als als Evidenz nein aber
dahinter meine ich steckt etwas ganz
ernsthaftes
wir wollen keinen Verbotsstaat sein wir
wollen doch eigentlich ein Land sein wo
wir den Menschen zutrauen dass sie frei
entscheiden dass sie auch über ihre
Gesundheit frei entscheiden dürfen und
ich meine dass jede Regelung die am Ende
zu einem zu weniger Regulierung führt
erstmal einen Schritt in die richtige
Richtung ist und ich glaube man kann die
Menschen das Zutrauen man kann den
Menschen vertrauen und sagen ihr wisst
schon welche Dosis richtig für euch ist
es kommt darauf an dass ihr euch nicht
sinnlos betrinkt in dich sinnlos zukifft
nicht zu schnell Autofahrt oder einfach
nicht immer übertreibt aber dieses
Grundvertrauen in den Menschen die finde
das sollten wir haben und das ist ein
außerordentlich liberativ liberale
Ansatz ganz spannender Punkt weil das
ganze kommt ja nun gerade von Karl
Lauterbach unserem Gesundheitsminister
beim Thema Corona sehr respektive auf
der anderen Seite jetzt aber doch mal
ein Versuch Eigenverantwortung
zuzulassen
und dort ist es hineingekommen nicht auf
auf Ansinnen der SPD sondern damals auch
wenn Sie den Grünen und der FDP ja also
und Lauterbach vollzieht jetzt etwas die
SPD war eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag
weil die noch so ein bisschen hin und
ich wollte ich wollte nur auf die
Eigenverantwortung hinaus auf das Thema
Eigenverantwortung dass er sehr viel
dafür angefeindet wurde beim Thema
Corona ja das heißt okay Gegenteil man
hat gerade in der corona-zeit hat sich
ja gezeigt dass die Frage des also der
persönlichen Einstellung zur Frage des
persönlichen Risikos und der
Eigenverantwortung komplett abgeschafft
worden ist und man uns ständig quasi
erklärt hat wir könnten nicht für unsere
eigene Gesundheit sorgen genau und und
wir müssten quasi zwangsweise vom Staat
die Regeln übernehmen
ich bin grundsätzlich bei Ihnen nur dann
sage ich okay dann müssen wir das aber
auch ausweiten und ich habe dann
allerdings immer noch eine Schwierigkeit
weil die Frage ist wo hören wir dann zum
Beispiel auf also ich sage mit dieser
Argumentation dass man sagt wir
vertrauen darauf dass die Leute ihren
Gesundheitsschutz selber ernst nehmen
müssen müssen wir dann alle nicht
eigentlich alle Drogen nach dieser
Regelung freigeben also nach dem Motto
was geht es mich denn an irgendwie wenn
ein anderer sagt ich möchte aber nicht
rauchen sondern ich nehme immer diese
Pillen die Vertrag ich besser oder die
finde ich toll oder ich nehme ich nehme
Crystal oder der anderen nimmt sonst was
ja also die Frage also irgendwo wenn man
zu anfängt so als so zu argumentieren
muss man natürlich auch schauen irgendwo
muss man ja trotzdem wieder einsetzen ne
und es gibt dann genau wir müssen immer
irgendwo Grenzen setzen weil es gibt
natürlich auch selbst schädigendes
Verhalten wo man sagt das können wir als
Gesellschaft eigentlich gar nicht
hinnehmen zumal die Gesellschaft ja die
Folgekosten trägt also jeder der sich
zuballert und und krank wird dauerhaft
krank wird oder Schäden verursacht für
die Zahlen wir ja insofern irgendwie ist
das schon können wir das nicht einfach
so freigeben mal aus ihrer Sicht Herr
peruanovic sie sind der jüngste jetzt
hier in der Runde so in ihrem Kreis
haben Sie das Gefühl dass ich dazu
geballert wird mit Kiffen und ob es ein
Unterschied machen würde ob es legal ist
oder nicht geht es da eher um
Entkriminalisierung oder sagt man ja
endlich kann ich alles machen was ich
will und jetzt kann ich mich richtig
darüber zu hauen nein also in meinem
Freundeskreis wird tatsächlich sich mehr
die Rübe zugeballert mit Alkohol
tatsächlich ja das ist wirklich
überhaupt kein Problem Bewusstsein da
dass das sind irgendeiner Form schädlich
ist das ist Thomas saufen weil man ein
Thema ist es immer noch ein Thema das
also
das ist kein Thema mehr aber
ich war nie der große Konsument von
Drogen aber beim Alkohol ist es ja genau
das Gegenteil der wird sogar das ja
abgekühltet irgendwo ne wir haben das
beim Oktoberfest gesehen da biedern sich
auch Politiker an mit Alkohol da fließt
der Alkohol in Strömen und was dort
passiert das ist ja eines eines
zivilisierten Landes in Deutschland das
sind alle Parteien dabei genau das sind
alle Parteien dabei und ich finde im
Vergleich den sie aufgetan haben auch
sehr gut weil ich finde es richtig dass
man über die Gesundheitsrisiken von
Cannabis spricht die gibt es ja auch in
meinem Freundeskreis oder ehemaligen
Bekanntenkreis gibt es Leute die
nachhaltige Schäden davon getragen haben
tatsächlich aber bei dem Alkohol ist das
natürlich ja auch der Fall und wenn ich
vielleicht eine Anekdote erzählen kann
ich habe drei Jahre in den Niederlanden
gelebt dort ist es ja seit sehr langer
Zeit legal und da gehst du in den
Coffeeshop dort kaufst du das und mein
Eindruck ist dass für die Holländer für
die Niederlande selber also meine
Studentengruppe für die hat das
überhaupt keine Rolle mehr gespielt das
waren vor allem die deutschen Touristen
die dann in die Niederlande gegangen
sind um dort in den Coffeeshops sich die
Sachen zu holen also ich glaube man
könnte auch eine gewisse Entzauberung
vollziehen wenn man Cannabis jetzt
legalisieren würde
gibt es Menschen in Ihrem Umkreis wo man
sagen die kiffen sich das Leben einfach
auch ein bisschen schön es ist ganz
schön hart hier und man kann auch
einfach mal sagen ja warum nicht das
hilft mir zu entspannen das hilft mir
auch einfach mal ein bisschen
abzuschalten und einfach mal zu sagen
sind wir gerade sein lassen
ich kannte so Leute tatsächlich ja jetzt
hat sich vielleicht auch harmonisch mein
Freundeskreis ein bisschen so da
differenziert dass nicht mehr die Kiffer
dabei sind wie gesagt das ist mehr der
Alkohol aber ja ein guter Freund von mir
von der Schule ja hat hadert immer noch
tatsächlich damit und das ist mir so ein
Gedächtnis geblieben weshalb ich jetzt
auch nicht sagen würde dass das alles
kein Problem ist und so aber haben wir
tatsächlich ein größeres Problem mit
Alkohol oder haben ein größeres Problem
mit Drogen mit anderen Drogen so
vielleicht mal haben sie zahlen also
vielleicht nur mal Salz aus meiner
Praxis jetzt was ich so mitbekommen also
die meisten fangen natürlich mit
Cannabis an und dann kommen dann später
die härteren Drogen und wenn das
legalisiert wird dann wird das ja
sozusagen dann hat man die Auswahl
zwischen Alkohol Cannabis und dann
natürlich die härteren und ich kenne
sehr viele Fälle so die dann je nach
sozusagen Veranstaltungen oder je nach
sozusagen anders unterschiedliche Drogen
konsumieren und jetzt mit der
Legalisierung gerade jetzt auch in der
jetzigen Phase also wir wirklich an
vielen verbots- und regulierungs- ins
Wohnzimmer den Regulator auf 18 Grad
stellen wollen dann kommt man mit so
einer mit so einer
pseudo-liberalen sozusagen Idee wo man
das das kommt auch nicht sehr
authentisch und ehrlich bei der
Gesellschaft an ja also ich kann nicht
auf der einen Seite sozusagen sagen Sie
haben noch nicht mehr es ist nicht in
der Lage die Maske selber zu tragen aber
sie dürfen sozusagen jetzt Cannabis noch
und dürfen die auch zu Hause sozusagen
züchten ja also ich meine der ganze
bürokratieapparat der dahinter dass die
Kontrollen die ganzen Möglichkeiten das
ist ja das muss man ja berücksichtigen
offenbar vor dass man 30 Gramm haben und
drei Pflanzen drei weibliche stellen Sie
sich mal vor die eine ist halbwegs sie
wollen eine neue kaufen dürfen sie das
haben sie dreieinhalb viel spannender
finde ich noch mal die Frage nach den
THC Obergrenzen da wäre ich dann
tatsächlich bei Ihnen also für
Jugendliche das dann zu kontrollieren da
frage ich mich wie man das machen möchte
also es gibt viele Bereiche wo man wo
man sich fragt irgendwie zum Beispiel
beim Autofahren also die beiden beim
Alkohol hätten wir jetzt aber mal haben
wir eine Promillegrenze irgendwann
festgelegt ich bin der ich bin sehr
gespannt wie das wie das eigentlich beim
Kiffen dann laufen soll das sind ja auch
solche Dinge irgendwie kann dann kann
ich dann bekifft fahren darf die Polizei
mich überhaupt noch kontrollieren weil
es ist ja dann etwas legales also wenn
ich Auto fahre bin ich ja schon 18 darf
ich also legal kiffen aber darf ich dann
damit Auto fahren gibt es irgendwelche
Grenzwerte auch der Zoll also die
Polizei Gewerkschaft sagt das gibt ein
riesen Aufgabenfeld für den Zoll auch
weil das wird ja zu einer Ware die
versteuert werden muss also wir
versteuern dann Drogen in Deutschland da
sind wir tatsächlich schon mal bei einem
sehr guten Punkt in die Nummer
ansprechen wollte können wir es uns
tatsächlich überhaupt leisten auf solche
Steuereinnahmen zu verzichten wir sind
in einer größter Erde der größten Krisen
die wir je gesehen haben die Menschen
haben Existenzängste damit könnten wir
mal so richtig ordentlich Herrn Lindner
was in die Kasse spüren das bringt eine
ganze Menge also Alkohol oder überhaupt
Steuern auf Genussmittel darauf will
auch Herr Lindner sicherlich nicht
verzichten es gibt noch den anderen
Aspekt man kann natürlich auch prima in
Cannabis vom Anlegen also es gab mal
einen wahren
Berufsverband und das ist ganz gut
gelaufen also wer das in den letzten
fünf Jahren gemacht hat der ist nicht
ganz schlecht gefahren
also es ist auch eine finanzielle Macht
dahinter gut das wollen wir mal könnte
man aber zynisch sagen dass also der
Staat die Geschäfte der Drogendealer
jetzt gerne in die eigene Kasse lieber
spülen möchte gut aber es kommt in eine
Kasse und wir haben uns dann super also
dann dann bauen wir jetzt Kindergärten
aus Drogengeld besser als keine
Kindergärten zu bauen vielleicht ja
wieso also das ist das ist Drogengeld
und das Alkoholsteuer ist kein
Drogengeld ich finde gerettet ich finde
alle auch keine Zigaretten ist auch da
hattet wenn bei der Zigaretten steuert
da beschwert sich jetzt auch keiner
drüber dass wir damit Geld einnehmen man
sagt schon doch wir retten rauchen aber
sie würde mich über viele Steuern gerne
beschweren in diesem Land aber ich
glaube das ist der falsche Weg ist
sozusagen um Steuer ein neue
Steuereinnahmen sich auszudenken jetzt
quasi ins Geschäft einzusteigen für die
schon eine ziemlich steile These gut
also ich glaube wir beenden das das
kiffer-thema an dieser Stelle denn
Kiffer Steuer auch hin oder her
Deutschland hat ein ziemlich großes
Wirtschaftsproblem ein zunehmendes die
teuer Krise hat uns im Griff wie gesagt
viele Menschen haben Existenzängste tja
und Herr alkasch sie sind jetzt
Professor für Mikroökonomie und sie
halten die Russland Sanktionen für
absolut fatal und sie sagen die haben
einen großen Anteil daran erklären Sie
uns mal bitte warum ringfrei für sie ja
also ich bin natürlich überzeugt davon
dass man Russland jetzt irgendwo
natürlich auch zeigen muss das was sie
da jetzt völkerrechtlich
wiederrechtlich gemacht haben dass das
natürlich Einhalt geboten sein muss das
ist klar aber die Sanktionen dass die
natürlich dann dem sanktioniere auch
selber schaden das ist auch klar weil
sonst wenn man dadurch einen Beziehung
hat zu einem Land und dann ist dann der
sanktioniere und der sanktionierte
natürlich gleichermaßen betroffen und
ich sage auch nicht dass die Sanktionen
jetzt völlig sozusagen relativ sagen wir
mal wirkungslos sind also wenn ich
überlegt im Großstadt wäre normalerweise
sagen wir morgen vier Prozent gewachsen
nächstes Jahr jetzt haben sie eine
Schrumpfung von
-3%. das und Sanktionen die müsste man
natürlich so feinjustieren dass sie
langfristig halten können weil nur
langfristig bringen sie etwas und
natürlich auf die Militärtechnologie auf
die Möglichkeiten Russland sozusagen
diese auch zu begrenzen und da sehe ich
halt keine Feinjustierung sondern
einfach generell dann Ansatz wo man
viele Sanktionen angefangen hat und dann
hat man selber gemerkt da ja zum
Beispiel junge Mittel das bringt nichts
dann hat man das wieder gelockert die
Niederländer die haben das ein oder
andere gelockert dann haben die
Amerikaner selber einiges gelockert weil
man gemerkt hat also dass das von
vornherein handwerklich als falsch
gemacht wird insofern die Sanktionen
wenn sie dann einem selber deutlich mehr
Schaden und da muss man die Rolle von
Deutschland besonders verstehen wir sind
ein Exportland aber diese Exporte die
hängen sozusagen von Ressourcen von
günstigen importern aber sowie
importieren 1,2 Billionen und
exportieren 1,4 so das heißt also wir
haben hier so unseren bias und gerade
als energieintensives in Land sind wir
sozusagen daran abhängig an den
Ressourcen und es ist ja nicht nur Gas
und Öl was wir als Russland bekommen
sondern die ganzen Edelmetalle die
ganzen assistenung Gas oder wenn wir
jetzt sozusagen später über nuklear
sozusagen Kernkraft der dann auch das
uranium also viele unterschätzen das
Russland natürlich seit der
Oktoberrevolution eigentlich mit
Sanktionen gelebt hat ja das heißt also
wenn man das in akademischen geraden
jetzt vergleicht dann haben die Russen
vielleicht ein PhD in sanktions- und
umgangsanktionen da sind wir noch
Grundschüler und deswegen wirkt das bei
uns natürlich umso schlimmer und all
diese Möglichkeiten und diese Wirkungen
hätte man mit berücksichtigen müssen und
dann feinjustierte wirklich effektive
Maßnahmen was ist die Wirkung wie
schwarz sehen Sie für die deutsche
Wirtschaft wie stark treffen die uns
also ich denke wenn wir werden jetzt die
die Gaspreise zum Beispiel um mehr als
das Doppelte steigen dann ist es mit
unserer Ingenieurs Kunst vorbei ja weil
wir ohnehin schon teuer sind wir haben
sehr großen
sozialapparat wir haben sehr großen
gesundheitsapparat das ist auch gut und
schön das ist ja auch ein Zeichen
unseres Wohlstands aber um das alles zu
finanzieren sind wir auf günstige
Ressourcen günstige Energien angewiesen
und die kommen nun mal aus Russland die
kann man jetzt nicht so substituieren
klar man kann LNG kaufen dann ist das
das sieben zehnfache sozusagen dessen
was aus Russland und man kann alles
ersetzen technisch alles möglich sie
wollen aber sie wurden mit Putin reden
wollen jetzt ich war von Anfang an der
Meinung dass man natürlich diesen
Konflikt irgendwann
diplomatisch lösen muss also dass man
sozusagen halt auch Putin zeigen muss wo
er seine Grenzen sind und niemand weder
Putin noch sehr lensky werden hier mit
Maximalforderungen hier rauskommen beide
Seiten müssen sicherlich auch zu einem
Kompromiss hin und der Kompromiss war ja
in Istanbul ja auch sehr nah und dann
hat es ja dann doch nicht geklappt und
das Ende vom Lied ist ja dass dann
sozusagen die Forderungen der Russen bzw
das was sie an Territorien einnehmen ja
exponentiell steigt und dann fragt man
sich naja am Anfang hätten das auch ein
bisschen günstiger haben können also
insofern ist das auch da diese diese
Watte Politik also weight MC kommt eher
schadet er den Ukrainern und wie spüre
schon bei ihnen dass sie da nicht so
ganz zustimmen nein
sagen wir es mal so das was sie ja
vorschlagen ist im Endeffekt dass wir
kleinen beigeben und das das im
Endeffekt ja die Rechnung von Russland
aufgeht dass man nur lang genug
irgendwie er Krieg führen muss und nur
aggressiv genug sein muss um das Ganze
um im Endeffekt dann doch etwas zu
gewinnen was mir fehlt in ihrer
Ausführung ist eigentlich die Frage
nicht wie wie bekommen wir wieder Gas
aus Russland und unter welchen Umständen
sondern wie schaffen wir endlich eine
Energiepolitik in Deutschland die uns
insgesamt autark macht also die
grundsätzlich mal darüber nachdenkt dass
Energieversorgung auch eine
Sicherheitspolitik ist und dass diese
dass wir darüber überhaupt nicht reden
wir haben das finden Sie selbst auf der
Seite des Bundesumweltamtes wir haben in
Deutschland Gasvorräte für für unseren
Verbrauch in den nächsten 100 Jahren wir
müssten sie nur selber fördern das heißt
wir machen den frackingverbot kaufen
aber freckengas woanders das ist nicht
wirklich sozusagen schlüssig ja wir
schaffen die Atomkraft ab kaufen aber
atomstrophe aus dem Ausland ja
genau aber auch das ist ja nicht
schlüssig das heißt mir fehlt bei dieser
ganzen Überlegung fehlt einfach das
Konzept und das auf das warte ich nach
wie vor von unserer Regierung wie
eigentlich unser Land insgesamt
nachhaltig in die Zukunft gedacht autark
wird von all diesen Überlegungen wem wir
jetzt wie Entgegenkommen müssen damit
wir freundlicherweise Energie aus dem
Ausland mitbringen wäre für sie keine
Optionen man kann das auch nicht ich
glaube dass diese die die Sanktionen
Grund selbstverständlich Schaden die
Sanktionen auch Deutschland das sieht ja
jeder also wie das abzustreiten ist ja
Banane aber die Frage ist was steht
insgesamt auf dem Spiel also meine
Befürchtung ist eigentlich wenn man
jetzt hier einlenkt dass das Putin das
nicht so versteht wie wir das gerne
verstanden wissen wollen sondern dass
das eine Ermutigung ist demnächst weil
anders
und nein es gibt ja auch noch andere
Länder es gibt ja noch andere Länder ich
meine nicht umsonst nicht umsonst
irgendwie drängen drängelte drängeln
jetzt Länder in die NATO weil sie sehen
es ist eine Gefahr und diese es ist
schon vor 15 Jahren falsch gemacht
worden
dass man da nicht schon reagiert hat und
gesagt hat Moment das nicht wer
annektieren keine Länder mehr mitten in
Europa und jetzt wäre sozusagen wieder
eine Ermutigung und das ist das was ich
befürchtet diskutieren jetzt auf der
einen Seite über Sanktionen da kann man
fällt mir einiges sein und auf der
anderen Seite diskutieren wir darüber
wie soll eigentlich dieser Krieg
weitergehen oder zu Ende gehen da sind
ja aber natürlich Sanktionen ein großer
Teil davon aber ich würde das ich würde
das wirklich zwei Teilen das eine zum
Thema Krieg sollen wir mit Putin reden
natürlich sollen wir mit Putin reden
sonst also
es ist dringend geboten ich glaube wir
rücken wirklich jeden Tag in dem diese
Auseinandersetzung eskaliert und das tut
sie rücken wir am dritten Weltkrieg
näher und den möchte ich nicht erleben
die möchte keiner von uns erleben also
müssen wir alles aber auch wirklich
alles dafür tun dass du verhindern
der putin ist unberechenbar und das ist
ja sein das ist ja auch seine Karte die
er spielt dass man nichts genau weiß das
ist das ist eine Strategie insofern
traust ihm zu vielleicht macht das
vielleicht macht das nicht das ist jetzt
nicht das
aber auf jeden Fall den Draht zu diesem
Machthaber zu diesem Diktator weiter zu
suchen und immer wieder auch zu
versuchen dort die Diplomatie ins Spiel
zu bringen das ist glaube ich ganz ganz
wichtig das andere Thema Sanktionen ich
glaube mit Sanktionen das ist die
einzige mögliche Antwort unterhalb des
militärischen Eingreifens die einzig
mögliche Antwort der EU oder des Westens
auf diesen Überfall waren Sanktionen die
lösen einen Wirtschaftskrieg aus und in
einem Wirtschaftskrieg gibt es nur
Verlierer aber beide Seiten verlieren
bringen die denn was diese Aktion ihre
Meinung was die bringen was und das
lässt sich an einem ganz einfachen
Beispiel auch belegen sie haben Recht
die Sanktionen tun uns sehr sehr weh all
das was hier passiert 19 Grad im Winter
das tut wirklich weh
aber nach all dem was wir jetzt
abschätzen können werden wir im nächsten
Jahr in eine Rezession schlittern wir
werden einen minus beim beim
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung haben das
Licht irgendwo zwischen 0,8 und -2% in
Windows nach allem was man von Russland
weiß wird es deutlich stärker ausfallen
wie die geringsten Schätzung liegen bei
-6% und da frage ich sie dann bringt es
bei uns doch eine ganze Menge mehr und
schadet Russland aber noch mehr also ich
muss da gegenhalten die
russische Wirtschaft ist also deutlich
widerstandsfähiger als man es behauptet
hat klar kann man natürlich jetzt
hingehen und argumentieren naja der
rubol ist stark weil sie wenig zu
importieren haben vielleicht haben sie
die Zahlen etwas frisiert vielleicht
haben sie die Zahlen also ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass ein Land wie
Russland jetzt die Zahlen völlig
sozusagen jetzt fälscht aber man kann
die so aggregieren dass vielleicht so
einige Zahlen nicht herauskommt klar ist
natürlich auch sozusagen bei
ölpreisbremse zum Beispiel könnte man
einführen aber Russland hat Schiffe um
90 Prozent des Öls woanders hinzubringen
auch bei Gas also auch bei sozusagen LNG
Gas können die natürlich die
Transportwege sind viel ich hatte auch
im Twitter darüber gestanden kriegt
keine Ersatzteile mehr für seine Schiffe
Russland
wir hätten ihn jetzt international
isoliert so ganz ist das natürlich nicht
so wir haben den Iran zum Beispiel der
jetzt übrigens zum Beispiel auch wieder
Cola-Dosen
die dann einfach ausgehebelt also heute
zum Beispiel Südafrika gesagt naja ich
beteilige mich nicht jetzt an diesen
Sanktionen also vor allem jetzt in die
Yachten und so und wir machen doch eine
Gefahr wir schießen uns deswegen ins
nicht nur ins eigene Knie sondern
vielleicht auch in andere Körperteile
weil wir sozusagen diese diese diese
Blockbildung und das sind die Russen mit
ihrer charming-offensive deutlich weiter
als wir haben ein alter
da steht auch eine Rolle in diesem in
diesem ganzen Türkei also die versucht
jetzt aber mal so ein Mittelding zu
führen die die Ukraine
ja aber macht doch Sinn aus türkisch
also die Türkei bekommt jetzt günstiges
Geld günstiger Gas die bekommen günstig
sozusagen Öl und äh haben doch sozusagen
auch die mit dem mir also diese
Kreditkarten links was ja auch ein
völlig ja eigentlich ein schwieriges und
schwierig schlechtes ähm
sanktionsmechanik weil das wirklich die
Bürger getroffen hat ja und es trifft da
die Bürger doch ganz anders als bei uns
ich meine die haben eine Situation die
durch die Decke geht nein also auch die
Inflation geht nicht durch die Decke die
haben die Inflation von 13%, die haben
eine Arbeitslosigkeit von 4%, also das
ist alles so ein bisschen man muss die
Zahlen wirklich mal differenziert
betrachten und deswegen sage ich ja
nicht ohne Grund dass diese Sanktionen
uns mehr Schaden ich habe von der Türkei
gesprochen achso ja Türkei ja das sind
aber über 80% das sind aber und deswegen
kann natürlich auch ein Erdogan den kann
man kritisieren in anderer Stelle aber
in dieser Politik hat mit diesem
Mittelweg schon eine richtige richtigen
sozusagen Ton getroffen das aber ist
nicht wenn man wenn man sich diese
Blaupause anschaut was passiert denn in
unserer Gesellschaft müssen wir jetzt
irgendwo sagen ja wir müssen auch mal
mehr ein bisschen was geben dafür dass
es Frieden geben kann müssen wir auch
mal ein bisschen leiden oder ist man
dann einfach sagen nein kann man immer
nur auf sich selber schauen aber das ist
das denn für ein Frieden entschuldigen
sie sagen was müssen wir geben um
Frieden zu geben ist das den Frieden
wenn wir jetzt Putin die halbe Ukraine
überlassen dafür dass Sie dass wir
wieder Gas bekommen und ist das ein
dauerhafter Frieden ich meine vor 15
Jahren hatte die Krim genommen jetzt zum
marschiert der ganze in das Land ein sie
glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass wenn
wir jetzt sozusagen in die halbe Ukraine
geben dass er nicht in paar Jahren kommt
und sich und und sozusagen
weitermarschiert um den Rest auch noch
zu bekommen Frage ist also das ist ja
kein Frieden nee die Frage Frieden sind
wir bereit als Deutschland zu gehen auf
was wollen wir verzichten sozusagen
damit wir das mit genau das nicht
passiert also vielleicht man Sanktionen
zu akzeptieren und weiterzumachen also
vielleicht noch mal dazu die uns treffen
also vielleicht vermeintlich härter als
ihnen die These ist also vielleicht dazu
was ich meine es geht doch nicht darum
dass wir als Bürger einen Winter davon
sterben wir nicht also wir werden auch
einen Winter vielleicht auch zwei Winter
mit etwas Kälte über aber es geht um die
Industrie wenn die Industrie einmal weg
ist also heute war BASF das sind viele
Unternehmen die jetzt pleite gehen viele
sind kurz davor reduzieren sozusagen dem
Energiebedarf und dann freuen sich ein
paar Ökonomen sagen als schaut mal hier
wir sparen Energie wir sparen nichts das
sind Unternehmen die die Produktion
drosseln und wenn die einmal weg sind
dann sind sie für immer weg dann kommen
sie auch nicht mehr zurück es geht ja es
geht also nicht irgendwie dass der
Bürger natürlich was dafür zahlen muss
das ist klar dass ich finde auch dass
die Ukraine einen wohlschuld und eine
Bringschuld hat gegenüber dem Westen das
fordern und völlig legitim und ich
verabscheue auch diesen Krieg aber es
geht um deutsche Interessen hier und ich
muss da sagen dass wir da einfach
vorsichtiger mit diesen ganzen
Sanktionen sein müssen dass wir
sozusagen am Ende gerade Deutschland so
ein Land was zu groß wie die Europa ist
aber zu klein für die Welt zu in der
sandwich-position das sind so Länder die
jetzt in der Kritik stehen und wir bauen
jetzt Anfang ab von allen Seiten und
dann müssen wir mal schauen ob das Ganze
wird es geht um Deutschland es geht um
die deutsche Position sagt Herr Aktas
wie wird das
diskutiert was glauben Sie wie ist das
in ihrer Generation jetzt also haben Sie
das Gefühl dass die Grundlage sozusagen
der Jugend jetzt auf dem Spiel steht
damit ein anderes Land die Ukraine
gerettet wird oder sagen Sie nein das
ist eben auch ein Zukunftsmodell für uns
für die Jugendlichen das ist etwas was
Europa ausmacht was eine Globalisierung
aus was macht ein zusammen ausmacht dass
man eben auch füreinander da ist und
dann auch verzichten muss und vielleicht
eben auch mal ein bisschen was
durchmachen muss ja auf jeden Fall also
ich teile denke ich hier die Meinung
dass jetzt wenn wir die Sanktion
zurücknehmen würden dass das der
komplett falsche Weg ist wir würden
Putin wir würden angekrochen kommen und
er würde sich tatsächlich bestätigt
fühlen was mir in dieser ganzen Debatte
in der Energiedebatte viel zu kurz kommt
ist dass ja doch gerade jetzt die Chance
darin liegt dass wir doch viel mehr auf
Effizienz und auf erneuerbare Energien
und stützen soll also sie sagen wir
müssen unsere Energieversorgung
nachhaltig aufbauen an dem Wort
nachhaltig ist nichts falsch aber als
Beispiel bringen sie Fracking was ja im
Grunde die unnachhaltigste Energieform
ist die es gibt wir müssen im Grunde
müssten wir 2035 klimaneutral werden
wenn wir jetzt Tracking aufbauen
das wollen wir gleich noch ein bisschen
diskutieren ich möchte eigentlich noch
mal ein bisschen beim wirklich beim
Thema Wirtschaft bleiben und da möchte
ich dann eigentlich auch mal zu ihrem
Thema rüberkommen made in Germany das
ist ja nun auch ein großer Teil der
offensichtlich ja als Steak ist eben
durch diese Sanktionen auch sie sagen
aber es ist noch nicht zu spät wir
können das ganze noch retten made in
Germany hat noch eine Chance jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt welche Chance es hat
und wie können wir diese Chance nutzen
okay ich bin neulich in der Papierfabrik
gegangen und dort kam der dort kam der
Chef auf mich zu und sagte sie kommen an
dem Tag wo zum ersten Mal die
Personalkosten geringer sind als die
Energiekosten und das ist sozusagen die
der Abgrund von dem wir stehen den sie
eben auch angesprochen haben
und die Frage ist wie gehen wir jetzt
damit um und jetzt kann man der Meinung
sein und das würde ich unterstützen dass
das eine Form auch von kreativer
Zerstörung sein kann
der Krieg in der Ukraine die hohen
Energiepreise können ein Booster sein
für Innovationen und darauf setze ich
eigentlich dieser Booster der muss zwei
verschiedene Wege gehen das eine ist er
muss innovative Wege aufzeigen um
Energie zu sparen und da sind die Firmen
dran sie haben eben BASF erwähnt BASF
zum Beispiel sitzt an einer gigantischen
wärmepumptepumpe das wird die größte der
Welt die die bauen zusammen mit man und
die versuchen dann die die Prozesswärme
dort selbst zu erzeugen das ist das eine
also Energiesparen und das andere ist
Innovationen in Form von neuartigen
wegen Energie zu erzeugen wie kann ich
was gibt es denn eigentlich was ist noch
in der Fusionstechnik drin was steckt
noch in der Kernkraft drin können wir
vielleicht Fracking tatsächlich
umweltschonend bei uns hinkriegen diese
Innovation zu fördern ich glaube darin
liegt eine große Chance
es bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig
glaube ich aber mir fehlt also ich sage
ich bin ja absolut bei Ihnen dass dass
man jetzt neu denken muss also dass man
dass man einfach Dinge auch jetzt mal
durchdenken muss an die man sich jetzt
jahrelang geleistet hat nicht
nachzudenken müssen wir uns dann auch
ein bisschen als von der Exportnation
Bundesrepublik verabschieden müssen wir
eine ganz neue ganz neu denken
das glaube ich nicht weil weil ich sie
können ein ganzes Land nicht einfach
umkrempeln aber Krisen sind ja eben
insofern das Positive an Krisen ist dass
sie Ausnahmen von der Regel zulassen
oder auch erfordern ja das heißt viele
Dinge die vorher nicht möglich waren zu
diskutieren muss man dann in der Krise
diskutieren weil einem nichts anderes
übrig bleibt und deswegen sind Krisen
eigentlich immer eine große Chance eben
auch für Innovation aber eben auch die
Chance sozusagen festgefahrenes
Gedankengut auch vielleicht über Bord zu
werfen und zu sagen wir müssen jetzt neu
denken weil das was wir uns ausgedacht
haben hat nicht funktioniert und
deswegen auch die ich bin würde ich
sagen kaum jemand in diesem Land ist ja
gegen den weiteren Ausbau irgendwie von
erneuerbaren Energien aber damit können
sie halt in ein Industrieland einfach
nicht führen das heißt wir brauchen ganz
andere industriemengen als wir
herstellen können jetzt nur durch
erneuerbare und schon gar nicht
kurzfristig und wenn man sowieso darüber
also wenn man sowieso die Alternative
ist dass man zum Beispiel sagen wir mal
schmutziges Gas von woanders kauft warum
sozusagen nicht das eigene Gas nehmen
also es ist nahezu paradox welche
gedankenbarrieren wir haben einfach aus
ideologischen Gründen und deswegen finde
ich es gut wenn man in dieser Krise ja
sagen wir mal experimenteller wäre
aktuell
tatsächlich war Deutschland immer ein
Vorbild auch für die Türkei wie wird es
heute gesehen nimmt man uns eigentlich
noch ernst nein also das kann man ganz
offen sagen also in der Türkei wird über
Deutschland das ist nur kopfschütten ich
hatte vor zwei Monaten war ich mit der
bei der Präsidium der dhp also der
türkischen haben wir auch beim
diskutiert ich sagen also wie können die
so eine Politik machen also ich bin ja
hier aufgewachsen ich habe diesem Land
sehr viel zu verdanken ich liebe dieses
Land auch und deswegen kritisiere ich
das auch auch als Beamter ich weiß dass
dass man sich damit ja auch nicht sehr
beliebt macht aber darum geht's mir
nicht mit Liebesentzug kann ich leben
aber ich kann nicht damit leben wenn man
kreative Zerstörung finde ich gut aber
das was wir machen ist eine unkreative
Zerstörung der Industrie und eine
bewusste Zerstörung unserer Industrie ja
weil Sparsamkeit also kein Land ist doch
sparsam wie Deutschland ja also ich habe
meine meine in meinem Studentenzeit hat
man hat man schon über Contracting und
über Energie und Sparsamkeit das war
doch immer deutsches sozusagen Gebot ja
und jetzt sozusagen den Leuten jetzt so
zu suggerieren man könnte mit ein
bisschen sparen und ein paar Waschlappen
jetzt aber Energiekrise
beobachten also ich finde ihre ihren
Ausspruch in der Türkei lacht man
übrigens das finde ich prima das ist so
kann man sich hier auch mal wirklich gut
merken aber ich glaube das gilt wenn man
sich die politische Entscheidungswege
hier anbelangt also ein großer
Energieverbraucher zu sein eine große
Industrie zu haben aber sämtliche
Energieträger abzuschalten oder Atom und
Kohle gleichzeitig das ist sicherlich
etwas was in der Türkei auf
Unverständnis stößt aber auf der anderen
Seite und das ist ja das was ich meinte
auf der anderen Seite haben wir nach wie
vor eine hoch kreative Industrie und die
denken sich was aus und ich bin einfach
ja ich bin am Ende fortschrittsgläubig
ich glaube dass wir in einer Krise sagen
sie unkreativ im Gegensatz zu kreativ
weil die die sozusagen die
Industrialisierung digitaler Wandel
Klimawandel das benutzt man in
Deutschland so gleichzeitig das sind
völlig unterschiedliche Wege also bei
der die beim digitalen Wandel da geht's
wirklich sozusagen am Abkühlung und
downskilling weil viele glauben na ja
wenn man sozusagen bisschen Innovation
dann hat man immer nur ein Roboter dann
braucht man nur sozusagen Techniker
Ingenieure nein auch dann braucht man
gerade
Variante Arbeiter die wirklich sozusagen
von Robotern gesteuert werden so und
wenn man sozusagen das heißt also immer
wieder energieintensiv und diese diese
Ideen sozusagen auch mit mit
Nuklearenergie wo kommt denn der uranium
her dass ich mal die Amerikaner
müssen jetzt waffenfähiges uranium
nehmen weil sie an Russland sozusagen
also Russland ist nicht ohne Grund in
Schachspieler ja wir spielen vielleicht
mensch ärger dich nicht gut aber das
sind die deutlich strategische und ich
glaube nicht dass der Putin ein manyakis
also er ist kaltherzig er ist brutal
aber ist rational
und deswegen ja und
Innovationsstandort Deutschland ja wenn
Sie das Thema Uran ansprechen es stimmt
ganz viel Uran kommt aus Russland aber
unterm Strich sind 20%. das heißt 80
Prozent kommen woanders her dann kommen
noch ein bisschen was aus Kasachstan
aber 60% kommen mal aus ganz anderen
Ecken das heißt ich glaube dass man mit
diesem mit diesem Material auch aus
unverdächtigeren Quellen genug beziehen
kann um entsprechende Forschung erfahren
zu treiben das ist sicherlich ist
sicherlich ein Weg und noch mal die
Innovationen die die Industrie schafft
die hat uns die letzten 200 Jahre
begleitet und warum soll das jetzt mit
einmal aufhören
ich bin überzeugt klar ich bin selber
innovationsfan und ich mag Schumpeter
mit für seine aber die Innovation
erfordert monopol-gewinne so diese
Gewinne müssen sie erstmal
erwirtschaften und bei diesen
Energiepreisen können Sie von froh sein
wenn sie sozusagen nicht pleite gehen
und da haben sie überhaupt auch keine
Innovation sozusagen Möglichkeiten oder
genug Profite um Innovation zu stecken
das ist ja sozusagen da fängt das Thema
an und ich sage ja wir sind wir haben
super Ingenieure wir haben super
Produkte aber diese Produkte die gehen
nur dann wenn wir sozusagen auf die nie
günstigen import-stoffe sozusagen
Rohstoffe und Energie das ist ja nicht
nur Gas es ist nicht nur sondern
Platinium oder auch sozusagen jetzt
Palladium oder von mir aus Nickel oder
Xenon was man sozusagen für die also
vieles kommt ja also Russland ist quasi
wie so ein Supermarkt für die Industrie
und da muss man dann halt mal dran
denken
ist voll auch mit diesen Stoffen von
woanders und Sie müssen sie können sie
wollen also
die Innovation sozusagen von von einem
von einem russischen
sie behaupten jetzt dass wir Russland
bräuchten um innovativ zu sein und das
ist ja doch aber sie behaupten eine
Abhängigkeit über die wir eben auch noch
nicht innovativ nachgedacht haben wie
wir diese Abhängigkeit abbauen können
das wäre zum Beispiel auch eine Form von
Innovation dass man sagt das kann doch
nicht sein dass wir abhängig sind quasi
von Russland und jemanden wie Putin
erdulden müssen mit all dem was
erfordert und mit der Kaltherzigkeit und
mit allem was Sie gerade ja auch selber
geschildert haben nur um selber noch
irgendwie unsere Energie unsere
Innovation oder sonst was aber
Innovation und Kreativität würde
bedeuten wie kommen wir aus einer
Situation heraus wo wir abhängig sind
von jemandem den wir gefallen müssen
also dieses Thema Abhängigkeit finde ich
ja sehr schön und auch sehr goldig aber
letztlich mit wenn man mit einem
Vertragspartner zusammen ist und er ist
günstig er ist zuverlässig das ist
diesmal Russland dann ist das Katar oder
China und wenn ich uranium nehme bei dem
Beispiel ich glaube die beide Länder
China und Russland haben über 60 Prozent
da können Sie jetzt einen sozusagen eine
Art
autoritäre Regime mit einem anderen
sozusagen ersetzen aber sie kommen immer
in eine Abhängigkeit also der Preise
sehen irgendwie egal wenn ich das also
sage okay es ist eigentlich egal
damit der Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland überlegen will ich sage das
nicht sagt nein ich sage es sind immer
irgendwelche sozusagen also ich meine
ist Katar jetzt ein besseres Land mit
dem Magazin die Geschäfte im Moment ja
also gerade kein Angriffskrieg gegen
sein Nachbarland also ich bin zwar auch
kein großer Freund von Katar aber
Russland führt gerade diesen Krieg und
dann müssen wir jetzt leider wechseln
und ich würde am liebsten auch nicht
nach Katar unsere die Energie dort von
dort besorgen aber ich weiß nicht wir
haben im Moment gar keine andere Wahl
und das ist doch der einzige Hebel wenn
wir diesen Krieg nicht eingreifen wollen
dass wir Russland wenigstens
ökonomischer Schaden und ja ich sehe da
keine Alternativ ich finde die Idee klar
dass man in der Not wird man
erfinderisch ja aber die
erfinderlichkeit sozusagen die
Erfindungen
aber die muss natürlich auch finanziert
werden und wenn wir sozusagen der
Industrie jetzt schon sozusagen das
Genick brechen dann ist es mit
Innovation vorbei ist wir brechen ja
nicht das Genick selbst die die stark
betroffenen Firmen sie haben BASF
genannt Bayern die großen Chemiefirmen
die Bayer hat vor vier Jahren Monsanto
für 60 Milliarden Dollar gekauft das
heißt da liegen unglaublich viele
Reserven die ist den möglich machen
jetzt in dieser Krise zu überleben das
sind ja auch nicht Firmen die nur in
Deutschland produzieren oder nur in
Deutschland verkaufen sondern die sind
weltweit aufgestellt und wenn es da
nicht
das andere Thema was eben Ansprachen ich
glaube wir brauchen auf Dauer einen
freien Handel wir brauchen auf Dauer
einen freien Handel mit China wir
brauchen einen mitrüsten ausgerechnet
auch mit China wir haben gerade das
Thema mit dem Hamburger Hafen und ich
finde es bemerkenswert wie der Kanzler
als ehemaliger Oberbürgermeister von
Hamburg sich als Held des Freihandels
mit einmal auch ich finde das gut die
glaube ich nicht so oder ich finde man
muss vorsichtig sein also gerade auch
die sagen wir mal die Erfahrung mit
Russland hat uns ja jetzt gerade auch
gezeigt wohin das führen kann wenn man
sag mal unberechenbaren Ländern weil
würde ich ihn nämlich auch sie sagten
gerade Russland sei zuverlässig mit
Verlauf nein Russland da weiß ich gerade
als nicht zuverlässiger Partner
unter diesem Aspekt finde ich es muss
man schon vorsichtig sein und fand ich
es sehr sehr erstaunlich mit welcher
Leichtigkeit Olaf Scholz sozusagen den
Chinesen auch durchaus einen Anteil
gegeben hätte wo sie in der
schwerminorität gehabt und jetzt hat man
es runter gehandelt aber die Chinesen
kaufen sich weltweit in die in die Häfen
ein und nicht überall
tut das den Ländern dort gut und die
Chinesen tun das mit einer großen
Strategie und das darf man jetzt nicht
vergessen also wir sollten lernen
eigentlich aus dieser Erfahrung mit
Russland dass man eben nicht zu viel
Macht geben darf gerade im
Energiebereich oder auch in der Logistik
einem fremden Land dass man nicht
berechnen kann ganz kurze Frage halten
Sie das für Doppelmoral
dass wir jetzt unseren Russland
unabhängig machen wollen und dafür in
andere Länder dafür entstehen sozusagen
in unserer Heften reinlassen ja auf
jeden Fall und am liebsten wäre mir
tatsächlich eine Wirtschaft die komplett
unabhängig von jeglichen diktatorischen
Regimen ist aber
wir haben nun mal diese Abhängigkeiten
im Moment und ja wir würden wir am
liebsten würden wir natürlich unabhängig
werden aber im Moment ist natürlich der
Fokus auf Russland dass wir von Russland
unabhängig werden und da natürlich Frau
baerbock sagt Werte geleitete
Außenpolitik noch wir stecken mit allen
Fingern mit allen Ländern in irgendwie
in Verbindung und deshalb ist das von
heute auf morgen nicht möglich obwohl es
natürlich wünschenswert wäre und deshalb
ist mir wichtig dass man halt eben auf
Russland jetzt sich konzentriert und
schaut weil Russland für diesen Krieg
dass wir von dort unsere Assets abziehen
und uns von Russland wenigstens
unabhängig machen auch für die Zukunft
und nicht nur jetzt in Zeiten dieses
Krieges wir sprechen gleich noch weiter
darüber wir kommen auch noch zu ihrem
Thema weil ein Kern sozusagen von made
in Germany den wollen sie nämlich
ankratzen die Autoindustrie da sprechen
wir gleich noch mal drüber wenn man eine
ganz kurze Pause bis gleich
[Musik]
ernst nehmen also genannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach acht fünf Köpfen
fünf Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Jürgen
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum wo
sollen die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
meinen Beifall in meine lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
bitte ist Baden ja man muss da ganz klar
jetzt mal auch darüber sprechen dass es
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
wo ist die Aufgabe von Journalismus
einfach die die Verlautbarung der
Politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
willkommen zurück hier bei viertel nach
acht und wir wollen gleich mit dem
nächsten Thema weitermachen es geht um
Autos das geliebte Auto der deutschen
sie möchten es tatsächlich abschaffen
zumindest in den Innenstädten eine
autofreie Innenstadt am besten gleich
morgen oder heute wie das genau aussehen
soll da bin ich jetzt sehr gespannt
legen Sie los Ihre Kamera genau also ich
möchte über die Verkehrswende sprechen
und vor allem auch über die Frage wir
wollen wir denn die Mobilität der
Zukunft gestalten so dass nicht nur
Autos auf ihre Kosten kommen und sich
sicher und frei bewegen können durch die
Stadt sondern auch alle anderen Menschen
die mit dem Fahrrad zu Fuß oder mit dem
ÖPNV unterwegs sind und leider haben wir
mit Verkehrsminister Wissing jemanden
der gar nicht genug dafür tut dass wir
unsere Klimaziele im Verkehr einhalten
und dass wir von der autodominanz
wegkommen und das hat auch der
klimabeirat der Bundesregierung im erst
vor kurzem bestätigt in seinem
Sofortprogramm dass dies bei weitem
nicht ausreicht um die Klimaziele bis
2030 einzuhalten und ja ich persönlich
hatte große Hoffnung zuletzt mit der mit
der Ampel das dort nach 16 Jahren
Stillstand endlich mal ein bisschen
Bewegung reinkommt aber das war leider
nicht der Fall und ja ich hatte es ja
schon erwähnt ich habe drei Jahre in den
Niederlanden gelebt und habe dort die
Erfahrung gemacht wie viel
Lebensqualität wir alle doch
hinzugewinnen können wenn wir nicht so
aufs Auto gucken wenn wenn es auch
einfach möglich ist ohne Kampfradler zu
sein sich durch die Stadt bewegen zu
können und das war eine wunderbare
Erfahrung das möchte ich nicht missen
und sehe nicht ein warum ich jetzt hier
in Deutschland darauf verzichten soll
das heißt sie sind wohl enttäuscht von
den Grünen
ich war sehr enttäuscht
ja ich war sehr enttäuscht als ich
gehört habe dass die Grünen nicht das
Verkehrsministerium kriegen damit hatte
ich eigentlich gerechnet und das ist
dann Herr Wissing gleich bekommt dann
bekommt der gleich mit der Schlagzeile
auf sich aufmerksam gemacht hat er sei
doch der Anwalt der Autofahrer also das
waren rabenschwacher Tag für mich und
leider ist das auch Programm also wir
sehen nicht dass der Wissing die großen
Dinge anpackt und Tempolimit ist
eigentlich eine symboldebatte es ist
eine sehr wichtige Maßnahme aber viel
wichtiger wäre es dass wir die
Subvention abschaffen die 30 Milliarden
jährlich in den Autoverkehr fließen und
das ist mit Herr bisschen leider nicht
zu machen also wenn ich das jetzt
zusammenfassen kann sie wollen eben
unbedingt ein Tempolimit haben auf den
Autobahnen und sie wollen aus unseren
deutschen Städten das Auto eigentlich am
liebsten komplett verbannen
wirtschaftlich überhaupt möglich
wir haben eine große Autoindustrie und
viel hängt an dieser Autoindustrie die
verdient auch viel Geld die nimmt auch
die autofahrerzahlen auch viele Steuern
also auf den längstlichen
aber dahinter steckt ja finde ich auch
wieder das Thema Verbot und da bin ich
genauso wie beim Thema Cannabis einfach
da bin ich nicht dabei wir können nicht
mit Verboten hantieren ich würde ihnen
total zustimmen wenn sie sagen okay das
Auto ist eine Dreckschleuder so wie es
im Moment gebaut wird und wir müssen
diese Emissionen vermeiden aber dann
sage ich doch in einem VW oder einem BMW
jetzt baut mir ein Auto dass diese
Emissionen nicht hat und dann kann man
genau das Wasserstoff E-Autos und das
ist doch eigentlich genau der richtige
Weg dann können wir auch mit diesem
Vehikeln fahren und mal nebenbei es gibt
viele Gründe dafür auch in der Mobilität
sie zu erhalten es gibt Menschen die
leben nicht entstehten die brauchen ein
Auto
ich habe auch viele Kinder wenn ich mir
in einer Stadt fahre und das Auto ist
voll was soll ich denn machen wenn ich
am Rand stehen bleibe und in den Bahn
muss das geht einfach nicht das ist
nicht praktikabel und dazu zum Schluss
autofahren macht auch Spaß also
bitteschön
warum sollen wir denn den Menschen
diesen Spaß den sie offenbar empfinden
manche sind auch immer noch stolz auf
ihr Auto manche putzen das jeden Samstag
die wollen das warum wollen wir Ihnen
das nehmen das ist doch eigentlich der
falsche
Firma freie Fahrt für freie Bürger war
das glaube ich ja das war was anderes
das da das war Freude am Fahren aber es
ist in der Tat so es leben ja nicht alle
Menschen in den Städten also ich finde
grundsätzlich würde ich es ist ja eine
schöne Sache wenn man sagt man kann man
hat Fußgängerzonen oder solche
Geschichten aber es muss das Leben ohne
das Leben muss ja praktikabel sein und
abgesehen jetzt sagen wir mal von dem
freiheitsaspekt der für mich auch der
wichtigste ist eigentlich nicht dass ich
mich Frage mit welchem Recht nehmen
sollen wir sollten wir den Menschen
etwas verbieten eigentlich
ist es einfach nicht praktikabel weil
der Großteil der Menschen in Deutschland
lebt ja nicht in Großstädten also wenn
ich in Berlin hier bin irgendwie dann
brauche ich auch kein Auto in den
meisten Großstädten kommt man eigentlich
auch viel besser mit öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln zurecht das sehe ich
völlig ein aber ich wohne zum Beispiel
auch in dem Randgebiet aber viele Kinder
das ist überhaupt nicht praktikabel ein
Leben es ist für viele ältere Leute
überhaupt ist sozusagen die einzige
Mobilität die Sie vielleicht noch haben
und deswegen finde ich ein bisschen mehr
Respekt eigentlich auch der persönlichen
Lebensführung gegenüber von von den
Leuten dass das eine persönliche
Entscheidung ist der eine steckt viel
gerne das eine der andere steckt viel
Geld in sein Auto und in der Tat die
Straßen und so weiter werden wir zahlen
alle nicht unerheblich Steuern für all
das was an Infrastruktur gemacht wird
und die Infrastruktur für Fußgänger für
wird ja nicht besteuert die für
Radfahrer wird auch nicht besteuert also
das ist so ja also wir brauchen das gar
nicht gegenrechnen
ist jetzt sehr sehr viele Punkte
gefallen ich möchte sie gern alle mal
abarbeiten zum Thema Verbote und
Freiheit das kann ich vielleicht
zusammenfassen die Freiheit des einen
ist auch immer die Freiheit des anderen
und in Berlin und erstmal ich rede nicht
über autofreies Land ich rede über
autofreie Städte also das ist eine
Debatte die müssen wir differenzieren da
möchte ich aber einmal ganz kurz
einpacken
und in Berlin leben 60% der Haushalte im
Innenstadtbereich haben überhaupt keine
Autor das heißt die Mehrheit besitzt
kein Auto und diese Leute werden in
ihrer Freiheit eingeschränkt sich so
vorzudenken wie sie wollen
mit Fahrrad durch Berlin
kein Auto anschaffen also sie behaupten
ja jetzt einfach nur dass 60 Prozent der
Leute quasi kein Auto wollen das ist
eine sehr besitzt ich glaube das sehr
viele einfacher ist sich gar nicht mehr
leisten kann Autos heutzutage wahnsinnig
teuer geworden allein schon einen
Führerschein allein schon Führerschein
zu machen es wahnsinnig teuer natürlich
der ÖPNV ist deutlich billiger als
Autofahren immer noch Benzin heutzutage
wissen wir wie es und durch die Decke
gegangen ist diese also da haben wir
eine Riesenproblem auch also genau also
zu diesen ich wollte noch mal diesen
freiheitspunkt machen es gibt auch eine
Freiheit jenseits des Autos ne wo
Menschen auch ihre Freiheitsrechte
wahrnehmen wollen und die werden mit der
Fülle ein Autos die wir in den Städten
haben leider mit Füßen getreten und zu
dem steuerpunkt also das ist ja alles
mal ausgerechnet worden ne Autos Zahlen
ungefähr 40 Milliarden steuern die durch
mineralsteuer alles mögliche reinkommt
der Staat zahlt in der gesamten
Aufrechterhaltung der Infrastruktur 70
Milliarden also das ist eine Differenz
von 30 Milliarden und das sind die
Umwelt und Klimaschäden noch gar nicht
aber das Argument Freude ein bisschen
Spaß am Leben dass man aber auch mal
sagt man muss vielleicht den Kompromiss
und Kompromiss hätte gerne auch als
Radfahrer Spaß am Leben und aber das
wird doch alles ausgebaut die
Radfahrwege werden ausgebaut kann man
nicht nebeneinander leben nein im Moment
ist das nicht möglich weil das Auto 70%
der gesamten Fläche wegnimmt obwohl es
nur für 25 Prozent der die
verantwortlich ist in Berlin das ist
eine das ist eine Schieflage und ja es
geht um flächengerechtigkeit dass die
Menschen die den ÖPNV nutzen ja
flächengerechtigkeit weil das Auto zu
viel Fläche wegnimmt könnt ihr jetzt
noch für alle an auf Kosten aller
anderen wahnsinnig lange über das Thema
diskutieren einmal nur eine Ja oder Nein
Frage haben sie einen Führerschein ja
fahren Sie Auto ich bin auf dem Land
groß geworden ich habe dort meinen
Führerschein gemacht tatsächlich ich
fahre hier in Berlin kein Auto ich habe
kein Auto ich fahre jeden Tag Rad fahren
Sie alle gern mal wenn sie nicht davon
überzeugt den mal eine Stunde lang mit
dem Fahrrad durch Mitte und dann werden
Sie vielleicht ein bisschen
nachsichtiger sein wenn es möglich wäre
dass alle Verkehrsteilnehmer mal in
Frieden miteinander nebeneinander leben
können das würde ich mir auf jeden Fall
wünschen ich habe nämlich das Gefühl
dass das momentan eigentlich eher Krieg
auf den Straßen ist hoffentlich war das
dann tatsächlich irgendwann mal gelöst
ich danke Ihnen sehr für diese Runde es
hat viel Spaß gemacht morgen geht es
wieder weiter wir bei viertel nach acht
danke schön fürs zuschauen
[Musik]